ah there's always something when you're
doing it by yourself
anyways welcome to
Griffin Les
do it
[Music]
welcome to
Yo absolutely
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to River
with Griffin doing it live once again in
full effect uh today's episode I'm going
in on the Kevin Durant issue and I'm
just getting back to some lighthearts
and stuff are we just talking about some
video uh some movies and TV shows
terminal list starring Chris Pratt the
Elvis movie and I'm finally giving my
final review of Obi-Wan so stay tuned
stay put baby
[Music]
this is
Ah that's literally my favorite part
about doing the podcast like I don't
actually don't have to do the podcast
after that you know what I mean
so oh I forgot man I forgot to do this
during that but welcome to
Ripper with Griffin starring Eric
Griffin your host and mentor and Big
Brother Eric Griffin I'm here for you
guys thank you for joining the show and
you know as always please uh you know
subscribe share all that stuff uh for
the channel that's always helpful uh I'm
also like I say I'm on Twitch
twitch twitch twitch so make sure you uh
hit me up on uh I'm there daily and if
you want to get some extra content you
know go over to patreon or basically
even if you just want to support me and
support what I do even if I'm not
putting a lot of extra content up but
I'm trying to I got a producer now if
you notice on my Instagram account I'm
putting more videos weekly about the
podcast so I'm slowly growing towards
where it's gonna be like major content
coming out all the time so thank you
guys for
being here as always I do appreciate you
okay so what's going on
um big news in the air Griffin uh
uh Community for me at least so I was on
uh I was doing King and sting actually
it was it wasn't even when I was doing
King of the sting it was just like
randomly I was talking to the guys but I
was talking to Brendan in particular and
you know he unfortunately couldn't come
to the wedding
um but he was like well let me get you
something he was like what do you want
you know what what wedding gift you want
you know and I said well I'd love a PS5
you know but I've said this to a couple
people I even said it to Santino
I was like I want bs5 because y'all want
something for me right so he was like
done you know and I just was like I
didn't think anything of it you know
because then he'd tell me later he was
like yo man I actually tried to get this
and it's like impossible to get so he
took that as a challenge
and my boy came through y'all
a boy came through oh yeah
so shout out to my boy Brendan Shaw got
me a PS5 PS5
PS5 gang
I was really touched you know I really
appreciated it you know it's like it is
what it is you know a lot of haters are
gonna hate but I don't really care y'all
don't know the real situation so I you
know
it's very it's very nice of him to do
that you know to go out of his way only
issue now I have is Rachel's all in my
case you know she's like oh is that our
wedding gift
she's like that's our wedding gift when
do I get to when do I get to play the
Xbox I mean the PlayStation she's like
when do I get to play it you know I was
like okay play whenever you want you
know she don't want to play it it's just
you know it's so ah my God it's so
frustrating
see like the whole wedding is her gift
you know what I'm saying the whole
wedding's for you
get the expensive dress she had you know
she had to have a dress she had to make
herself by a designer expensive you know
we went on this expensive honeymoon oh
this is for her can I get one thing can
I get one thing what do you guys think
you know ladies that are listening right
now is it is it terrible that I got that
one of my friends got you know one thing
for me is that is that out of pocket I
want to know what y'all think about that
you know what let's just put a poll up
and thank you for listening if you're
just listening right now and you have uh
I appreciate all the the the lessons I
get on Apple Spotify uh Amazon all that
all the places that you can listen
um
wait let's let's put a poll up fair or
foul PS5
gift for husband
[Laughter]
for groom actually I should say groom
um
father I know all the guys most of the
guys in here I know what you I know how
y'all gonna answer uh
uh anyways but I got some good gifts we
got some good gifts from people and we
have to actually start
uh sending out thank you cards to the
people that got gifts oh I see my boy
Vincent oshana is in the thing him and
his uh cousin Rumpson shout out to them
two of my good friends they got us this
Google Nest thing because I used the
Google thing anyway I have it for my for
it turns the lights on and stuff and I
have a speaker so it's good but just the
building that I live in I don't think we
could change the lock so we're gonna
have to hold on to it for something else
Rachel actually wanted to put it on her
closet door you know she was like well I
want my closet door locked I was like if
somebody's in the house if somebody's in
our place at that point they gonna kick
this door down you know but it is what
it is
I don't know what all people got and I
don't uh the gifts you know because we
got it it's on the registry but we
already had a situation because somebody
looked on the registry and by the way
this is a pro tip for you guys
that um when you're gonna buy something
for someone but you don't want to like
so let's say they have a registry we had
our registry at Bloomingdale's right so
let's say you have something on
Bloomingdale's like a mixer or something
right like a uh or like a bread maker
let's say
so you see on Bloomingdale's the bread
maker is like 500.
but then you go to Amazon and you go oh
man I can get the same bread maker for
300 and then you just you don't get the
bread maker on Bloomingdale's and you
get the bread maker on Amazon and send
it here's the issue though you have to
tell the couple
because what happened is that's what
somebody did for us they bought us
something that somebody already sent us
so we have two of the same gift because
we didn't check it off on the on the
registry so if you are going to do that
wedding gift tip so and it's actually
smart like you could go to people's uh
registry and you could see that they're
registered in some fancy place whatever
Bloomingdale's Wayfair whatever and you
see you can get that gift cheaper you
have to let them know because if you
don't let them know they're gonna you
know someone else might buy that because
it's not checked off on the list so
that's a tip out there so yeah so now
Rachel wants to like you know she wanna
she wanna use the PS5 you know she's
just
so I have some more wedding updates not
necessarily a wedding update but more
like a question for those people who are
already married okay
Rachel news so
this is a funny thing
to me it's just sometimes I feel like
your wife should come with a manual with
like an index of all the things that
we're supposed to know
my wife says this kind of stuff to me
all the time like you should know but
it's like
it's not like oh you should know I'm
allergic allergic to chocolate or say
it's not major big things it's these
little things where I'm like how am I
supposed to know that
Rachel's like a mug why with these like
instructions that that I didn't know
like you're not supposed to feed her
after midnight or she's gonna turn into
a monster or you know she got these
weird rules so we like we're about to
eat and I'll be like hey you want this
strawberry vinaigrette with the with
she'll be like you should know I don't
like strawberry vinaigrette with walnuts
on my spinach you should know this how
the hell I'm supposed to know that look
she says this to me all the time you
should know how how how am I how am I
supposed to know when did we have this
discussion they should all come with a
manual they should come with a manual
with like an index where you could go
okay strawberry vinaigrette just a
second let me go to that section okay
retali dressing Salad dressing Salad
Dressing here it is uh I gotta go to the
vinaigrette section okay vinaigrette
strawberry vinaigrette oh uh you uh
addendum one cannot have strawberry
vinaigrette with walnuts on spinach
after 4 P.M uh you know it's it's all
these weird things and by the way it
changes too so it's like you know it's
like the index book that you would get
for your wife it's it's like one of
those textbooks you know that they keep
changing so you got to get volume one so
I have volume one right now and I go to
the strawberry vinaigrette section but
like volume two gonna come out next year
and she's gonna buy you should know that
that's not a thing anymore that I love
strawberry vinaigrette with walnuts on
my spinach and I have to have it before
two o'clock so you go like so you you
have all these books and indexes of like
trying to figure out what the hell they
want and don't want
she says it to me so matter of factly
that I feel like how how did I not know
this you know she's very
matter-of-factly like you should know
that I don't like coffee
um with this type of milk and only one
spoon of honey you should know this and
like furious at me that I don't know
so that's some things I'm learning right
now
so funny
I was thinking about something that uh
I just oh before I oh man you know what
I forgot so we got to do it now damn it
this is like when you do stuff live you
forget but I forgot about my pre-rolls
so we got to do the pre-rolls now guys
uh shout out to Helix sleep uh Helix
sleep take their two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life find your perfect mattress at
Helix sleep.com and also five CBD five
CBD enter code Griffin thank you to our
sponsors they make full spectrum CBD and
THC products that you can really feel go
to 5cbd.com Griffin and enter code
Griffin at checkout for 30 off and free
shipping on your order
forgot we got to pay the bills
I'm still man I'm still thinking about
my honeymoon you know
I miss it's just it was so fun to be
like on vacation but there is one thing
that happened on my vacation and it just
made me think about something that I'm
dealing with with my wife with Rachel
I farted
on the honeymoon and it was probably
top five all time
you ever have a fart like that where
you're like oh this is wow it was it was
a wow it was like resonant D It came it
was windy you know what I mean it was
just a deep like like I felt like oh my
body needed this it just was like
you know what I mean like it was
it was just one of those ones where like
because you know we fart all the time I
mean everybody does but you know it's
rare that you have one where you go oh
man
because it was it was it was memorable
because I was sitting on the beach you
know laying on this towel under this
thing and the wind was blowing and I
just was like oh I feel this and then it
just was like
she Rachel wasn't even around she was
out swimming so don't worry it wasn't
like it was in front of her I it was
alone I was alone but it was just one of
those ones where I was like what hello
hello I think like ships hurt it and
we're gonna start coming into Shore that
like that's how powerful it was just
windy and and resonant
so she get but okay so like earlier
before I did the podcast took shower you
know and I was in the bathroom
she was in the bathroom we were she was
gonna take a shower I was gonna take a
shower so sometimes you know we I'll go
in first and she'll come you know stop
coming to the bathroom and I crack one
off and then she gets mad she's like oh
my God how disgusting we in the bathroom
we supposed to do it just whip not in
front of me every time I do it and when
I do it it's like you would have thought
you would have thought like I it's a
personal attack on her right it's it's
it's it's it's always like the worst
thing ever let her crack one off okay
and then she looks at me like well if
you hadn't given me that strawberry
vinaigrette with those walnuts like I
told you it's like oh it's my fault
Rachel is a master at making everything
my fault if it was an Olympic event she
would be a gold medalist in making it my
fault like at the weirdest times too
like at places where if I would have
farted when she farts I mean it would be
like I'd be sleeping on the couch okay
but she does it I'm looking at her like
did you just she's like well you know I
told you I wasn't hungry and you made me
that eat that food like what what how's
that I I forced it so
I don't know about you and this but this
is what why am I talking about this I
don't know because it's funny to me but
she said like that I fart too much and I
was like I don't fart too much I think I
fart at exactly amount of times I almost
want to Google what is the average
amount of farts per day like how many
times can you fart or do just a normal
person fart you know what let's just
Google it you know what I mean
normal amount of farting per day there
it is right there I love Google
doctors say the average person farts
anywhere from five to fifteen times per
day thank you there it is right there
I'm right in the pocket okay I don't
care what you say I am right in the
pocket of when you're supposed to
five to Fifteen that's the average okay
I'm right in there and I'm in the by the
way I'm not even on the high end she
thinks I'm on the high end but I'm like
in the middle in the middle range right
there so I mean what are you talking
about that's all I don't know is that
one of the things that you
you know that's one of those little
things you you argue about or you just
have to like let go in a relationship
I guess so I mean you just like you know
it is what it is there's no fairness
that's another thing too I I already
knew this that's the only reason why I
was I was already ready to get married
is because there's no fairness there's
there doesn't there's never going to be
fairness in terms of like how men look
at things and how women look at things
we don't look at things the same way so
that you can't be like well because I
let this go you have to let it go you
just kind of like work [ __ ] out and just
you know it is what it is but definitely
there is a uh farting discrepancy in the
household
laughs
oh man
so
let's get to some stuff that I uh wanted
to do that I haven't done in a while
like so mostly movie reviews today
there's so much crazy stuff going on in
the world so I was like you know what oh
and by the way I'm still showing my
honeymoon background that's why I was
thinking about it too you know I I just
it's just such a it was such a beautiful
setting but let's just get into some
stuff that has been going on and the
first thing is the Kevin Durant
situation so y'all know I've been
um
I've been I'm hard on Kevin Durant and I
think I I'm Justified I'm a fan I'm just
a fan you know what I mean but I have my
things I what I could see what I see I'm
I'm a basketball Aficionado you know I
saw what happened in Oklahoma City you
know they got to the championship they
didn't win KD had a couple of really bad
games in that Championship gaming and
they didn't win but they were young fine
to cut two they're playing Golden State
they're up 3-1 and once again when it
counted there was a couple of games uh
that they needed to win and Kevin Durant
had a couple of bad games they end up
losing that series then of course he
moves to Golden State
right he goes to Golden State and then
the you know everybody judges him for
that he wins two finals MVPs he wins two
championships he tears his Achilles
once again the relationship with that
organization fell apart with him with
the the players he moves on he probably
wanted to move on too because he got
tired of hearing the noise let me go win
a championship myself he picks to go
play with Kyrie Irving another guy who
has a history of just he's got a a weird
history he got hurt at Duke he never
even really played at Duke he came out
he was like I don't know if he was the
number one pick but he was a high draft
pick but he never really had an
experience played a lot because he got
hurt he goes to Cleveland they're
terrible LeBron James comes to Cleveland
they go to the championship four years
in a row he gets hurt the first year and
to me they would have won that
Championship with Kyrie Irving or even
with Kevin Love but Kevin Love and Kyrie
Irving got hurt that's his Mo Kyrie
Irving gets hurt they go on the next
year they come out he plays they win he
hits the big shot
um and they win the relationship between
him and LeBron James deteriorates
then that's the end Kyrie Irving's got
to go but in that process in that
process
now you're hearing reports about how
Kyrie Irving was a problem he was he
wasn't the easiest teammate and person
to deal with with teammates and
organization even when he was in
Cleveland
um and so then he goes to Boston that
falls apart Boston's better without him
when he plays it's like that's a hassle
then he trade he leaves there he goes to
the the Nets so but apparently from
reports him and Kevin Durant talked and
they wanted to play together and they
decided to play with the Nets so Kevin
Durant knowing all this stuff that he
sees whatever's going on he decides that
Kevin
um that Kyrie Irving is the one that's
going to help him win the championship
where he's the leader of the team it was
an epic failure listen to me epic
failure
from injuries to vaccine mandates to all
the reasons why Kyrie Irving didn't want
to play all you know social injustice
and he didn't want to play because
somebody called him the n-word he didn't
want to play because he was going to his
sister's birthday party you know all the
things that were Justified or under
Justified whatever Kevin Durant's the
kind of guy he's like I'm in the gym I'm
trying to win the guy's an official he
the guy is a savant when it comes to
basketball Kevin Durant is probably one
of the greatest basketball players of
all time but he can't catch a break with
this kind of stuff but he made a
terrible Choice he goes to the Nets with
Kyrie Irving I don't get it he should
have went to the Clippers even before
Golden State he should have went to the
Clippers I think they were they the
Clippers would have won that year but
anyways so now cut to this I'm super
hard on Kevin Durant
um because I think he could be better
deserves better from from himself and
from people around him right
it was a disaster and then they treat
then you know uh uh James Harden leaves
right James Harden leaves and they get
Ben Simmons who's going through some
nonsense with mental he's you know he's
he says oh it's mental health but turns
out turns out it might have been just to
get his money he just didn't want to
play and he needed something to say so I
don't know man so kept now I'm getting
to this I've been hard on Kevin Durant I
was hard on him leaving Golden State I
was hard on him even going to Golden
State I was hard on him leaving Oklahoma
City you know what good for you making
this choice right now Kevin Durant get
out of there I you know what I mean like
I am glad that he is out of there man
you know it's like at a certain point
you go I tried my best and I saw a quote
from him saying something like people
know what I do when I'm in this gym and
not everybody was in the gym who knows
what he's referring to who knows what
you know was it was he talking about
Stephen that's like he set that
situation up him and Kyrie Irving said
they don't need a coach they were the
ones who who were like oh we can do this
and they found out the hard way it's not
true they got spanked by Boston swept
when you get swept there's no excuse
okay there's no excuse all right losing
in a seven game series okay it's either
here or near and you could pick apart
certain decisions to find out well if
this would have been better you could
blame someone you could be like well
Steve Nash could have coached better and
they wouldn't have gone seven that kind
of stuff but when you get swept that
that's a indictment on you your players
your franchise you you know what I mean
so here we are so in this situation I'm
like you know what I'm for him good for
you I think get out of there admit you
you know what I made a mistake it didn't
work out I'm still in my Prime let me go
to some place and try to do this again
so here we are right now the question is
where is he gonna go because I've been
looking at I've been Googling stuff
about NBA rumors and I'm hearing some
weird ass stuff man one of the rumors
was him going back to Golden State
that
really sorry I just took a drink really
really you're gonna go back to Golden
State the place you left because you
thought you could do it better someplace
else now you want to go back oh man
the other one was going to Phoenix oh
you want to go to Phoenix oh so you want
to go to the other team that had the
best record in the League last year so
you want to go to that team man
well we already know now he went to a
team where he was supposed to be the
best player and the leader they fell
short so if he goes to one of these
other situations is showing that he's a
piece not the main piece but a piece you
know he's not uh you know the Shack on
the Lakers or even the Kobe later you
know even though I still even when Kobe
was like I think Kobe wasn't as big a
piece as Shaq was but he was the big
piece and you had Paul Gasol you had Ron
our test you had you know a a team and
you have Phil Jackson is also a big
piece of the pie
like when you take a piece let's say
take a piece of pie right think of a pie
and you have to slice the the pieces of
the pie what is the most important piece
of the pie so when LeBron James was in
Cleveland I think he was the largest
piece of pie there's ever been of of a
situation for championship team you know
in that situation right he was a really
large piece of the pie you know you have
the general manager you know so like
with the Lakers you know you had like
say go back to the Jordan's Bulls Jordan
had a big piece of pie but you know what
Phil Jackson also had a big piece of
that pie and so did Scottie Pippen not
as big as Jordan maybe even half but
then the The Supporting Cast had a piece
because of you know say horse Grandin
and Jim Paxton and then the next version
Tony CU coach and and Steve Kerr and you
know so you know but LeBron that year
they won that was a large piece of the
pie right
I don't think Kevin Durant can ever be
the largest piece of pie is what I'm
saying he got to be an equivalent piece
of pie like if he goes to Miami which I
think is a good destination Jimmy Butler
is an alpha dog he's a big piece of that
pie but he can't do it on his own Kevin
Durant would be another chunk of pie and
I think them together
along with Pat Riley Eric Spoelstra and
that culture could turn into something
you know what I mean
so we'll see so uh you know shout out to
Kevin Durant I talk a lot of smack about
the guy but I feel like in this
situation you know what you go
didn't work out I gotta move on and I
think that that's good that he's doing
that so that's my thoughts on that
okay where are we now
um yeah let's you know what let's go
into
[Music]
um
where is it I thought I had
oh man did I get rid of I think I erased
my Obi-Wan Background by oh no I didn't
hear this I thought I raced my Obi-Wan
Background by accident but here it is
guys so I know I was supposed to do this
last week but I forgot because so much
stuff was going on but let I want to
talk about the Obi-Wan finale let's just
talk about the whole series as a whole
so I thought the first two episodes were
great I thought it was good Nostalgia I
thought I was like oh this is a great
time period to talk about
because you know when we first like if
you if you're old as I am and you
remember the original Star Wars movie
Star Wars Empire and Return of the Jedi
when we first meet Obi-Wan he's an old
ass man
so then they made these new movies later
the you know the one supposedly one two
and three and then now you're getting
some backstory about you know this is
you know Obi-Wan and he you know he gets
uh Anakin and you know everything that
happens and then so then it's like so
they started the Obi-Wan series at 10
years after
uh he left Anakin on the on the on the
Volcano World where you know the I Have
The High Ground and you know the emperor
grabs him and turns him into Darth Vader
so this is 10 years later and Obi-Wan is
sort of broken remember you have to
remember that the Jedi have been
destroyed you know Anakin went crazy and
killed the Younglings and you know
destroyed the Jedi Temple and he went to
the dark side right so the Jedi are now
scattered around the universe Yoda's
gone everybody's gone right
and Obi-Wan she's trying to live his
life trying to like you know live in
Exile and be like you know what I I
can't be a Jedi anymore and and then
some Jedis have been converted by Darth
Vader to be inquisitors to find the rest
of the Jedi and remove them from the
plant from the world right and that's
where the Obi-Wan series picks up from
so you meet this sort of broken Obi-Wan
Kenobi right and uh you know we find out
that Darth Vader he finds out Darth
Vader who Darth Vader is and Anakin's
alive and it's this whole thing first
two episodes are great I liked them the
little girl playing Princess Leia
she's gonna be a great good actress one
day she ain't there yet that's the
nicest way I can say it you know it's
just with kid actors it's it's it's hard
to get like you know what I mean like
when you really get a a it's a special
child actor it's a tough thing she's not
there yet a lot of Charisma I see a
bright future for her okay
so three four three and four those two
episodes not good the story wasn't good
the acting wasn't good I just ugh but
five and six it really picks up
and when you look at the series on a
whole I give it a lot of woo-woos just
for nostalgia's sake I I really enjoy
that universe so they're not always
going to get it right but I enjoy the
universe
you know what I mean I
and I like how they you know you know
Darth Vader's powerful
but he's not the Darth Vader that we see
in Star Wars episode four
you know and so we got this thing and I
tell you after I watched the final
episode of the Obi-Wan series it made me
want to go watch Star Wars it did so I
went and I watched Star Wars you know I
was on a plane or whatever and I was
like oh you know what I gotta watch Star
Wars this is you know so
good for them I again I I give uh you
know Obi-Wan
maybe that's like four woo-woos so I
don't know if there's gonna be a season
two I doubt that there is they might
start something because at this point we
know what like it's hard to keep it's
hard to do a bunch of prequel stuff
because we already know what happens you
know what I mean like at this point we
know what happens so like I guess
another maybe I guess I don't know I I
don't think we want to see any more
stories about these people because we
know how it ends we know what happens to
Darth Vader and Anakin Skywalker he
redeems himself he was the one that
brought balance to the force you know
it's like ah we don't want to see all
that anymore there's not there's not
much more story you could tell and I
think they could have done up much I
think they could have done a better job
in terms of like because this is like a
really interesting time frame but I
think they did a serviceable job it
wasn't the best but I think they did a
serviceable job and I totally
recommend you watch it especially if
you're a big time
Star Wars fan
so I'll say that so that's my Obi-Wan
uh what do you call it thing there okay
all right
um
let's take some time now to go back to
talk for our sponsors guys the Helix
sleep man I have a helix sleep mattress
and I do highly recommend it sleep is
one of the most important things you
could possibly do every time I go to the
doctor when I go to some of these Health
places I do for like
um you know really working on my
hormones and all this stuff the first
thing they ask about it always is sleep
sleep exercise and what you eat those
are the three things that can change
your life so having a good mattress is
super important and especially with the
world we live in right now with
shootings and and politics you need to
have a good night's sleep so sleeping is
important healing sleep has a sleep quiz
that you could take it's just two
minutes you complete it and it helps you
figure out what kind of mattress is good
for you if you're a side sleeper if
you're heavy set if you're a stomach
sleeper back sleeper they have the
mattress for you I'm a side sleeper and
I and that's the kind of mattress that I
have so if you're looking for a mattress
like I say you take the quiz you order
the mattress and the mattress comes
right to your door shipping for for free
you don't ever need to go to the
mattress store again which is a hassle
and they'll actually if you have a
hundred days and they'll they'll return
it there's a 10-year warranty and you
get to try it out for 100 nights risk
free and they'll even pick it up if you
don't love it and I'm sure that you are
gonna love it Helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com Griffin
five CBD guys five CBD not a weed smoker
I don't even drink alcohol at all I'm
not this guy I don't necess I don't like
being high I don't like that feeling but
5 CBD is the spot it was founded by hemp
enthusiasts to unlock the power of full
spectrum CBD so you can unwind from the
grind if you don't want that like super
high feeling this gets you right there
it's so calming I love it I'll pop a
gummy at night and I feel that chill
it's like it's right there so it's the
essence you can think of 5 should be as
Extra Strength relaxation I love it 5
CBD has designed high quality affordable
and full spectrum products that help you
slow things down
life moves fast sometimes you need to
remind yourself to just kick back and
relax five CBD will help you with that
um riffing with Griffin listeners get 30
off and free shipping on their first
order of of uh five CBD
go to
fivecbd.com Griffin and enter code
Griffin at checkout for 30 off and free
shipping on your first order that's five
cbd.com Griffin and enter code Griffin
at checkout for 30 off and free shipping
on your first order
boom
business concluded
how are we doing guys and once again
thanks for being here
all right let me continue with my
reviews uh uh I saw the Elvis movie I
saw the Elvis movie last night
um
let's see is this it wait let me make
sure
yeah here we go
saw the Elvis movie last night guys
um
what did I think of it so wait let me go
here to the IMDb
um Elvis it stars what's his name
um it starts Tom Hanks Austin Butler and
Olivia
[Music]
DeJean oh I don't know what her name is
but it's really Austin Butler I mean
this dude this dude is a great actor
what do I think of the movie so baz
alert what is his name Lerman the
director this guy's a weirdo for sure
okay
um he like this guy like some other
movies that he's done
um he's done Romeo and Juliet
um he's just done some weird he's he's a
weird dude man
you know
he he like and so it's very artsy fartsy
with super long
I don't you know it's really like the
story of Elvis but it's not even really
the story of Elvis so much as is the
story of the perspective
of the the his longtime manager that Tom
Hanks plays who
sort of was scam and Elvis but at the
same time helped him become great you
know or or took advantage of his talents
and you know and this movie definitely
shows Elvis in a bright light uh
favorably you know
um things about Elvis I didn't know I
didn't know he grew up in a black
neighborhood I didn't know that he grew
up in like sort of a like poorer area
like like the poor black area but there
was like sections for white people to be
in this poor black area so he grew up
around black kids according to the movie
and you know seeing gospel music and he
always knew about you know he always was
a musician and then cut to you know he
records this record and he's got like
you know that he's got the spirit I mean
Elvis seemed to be just like a really
pure artist man when you look back of
footage of him or just like you know he
wasn't necessarily the greatest singer
but he had that thing Elvis had that
thing and this actor
um what's his name Austin Butler man he
really captures it man I don't know if
he captures Elvis but he captures
something that is just tremendous
um
you know
it's just it's CR it's incredible like
his performance where he must I don't
know you know I don't know what someone
like this is process is but whatever it
is it's fascinating to watch man you may
not you may not like the movie as a
whole or or like just I I don't know if
I like the way they told the story but
he made it really digestible with just
his passion as Elvis you know and they
glossed over a lot of stuff man you know
Elvis was a notorious womanizer and
stuff and uh
it's great how like you know um you know
they just again they I think that the
the people that own rights to doing
movies for Elvis are probably like hey
man we don't want to hear about that
stuff you know it's like what's her name
was like 14 years old when when he got
with her you know they they moved her
into Graceland when she was you know
underage you know you know so they don't
they gloss over there they mentioned it
one time it's like all he says is you
hear the voiceover of like I knew this
teenage love you know of this teenage
girl you know that's all they say you
know what I mean so it's like you know
and it's like do we want to do we want
to celebrate Elvis or do we want to tear
them down I mean you know what I mean
and it's funny even in the movie they
talk about he was already they were
already trying to cancel Elvis because
the world was so like weird back then in
comparison to how it is now so you know
you know and just showing the Artistry
of what Elvis was doing just being this
like man this like extreme artist man
like you could tell that
even when you see I was too young you
know like Elvis was already like washed
up by the time you know I I wasn't I was
born in 72 so like by 77 or so when he
died you know all you hear about is like
fat Elvis in Vegas you know
but who knows what he could have been
like he was already he's already such an
influence influential figure in history
right on music and stuff and who knows
and that's another thing too like
there's there's a there's a group of
people that talk about Elvis and they
just say well he stole black music okay
that's just how they talk about it but
the way the movie portrayed it to me
they were traded in a way that Elvis was
more honoring this he wasn't stealing it
so much as he was like yeah I want to
record that song that's how they did it
in the movie where he would hear a song
about oh man I gotta record that but
that's what everyone was doing back then
there was no like songwrites or whatever
I they they that came later so he was
recording songs that he knew and you
know so
if you want to look at it that way you
want to look at Elvis in a favorable
light there it is right there that's how
they do this in this movie they really
do show him in a very favorable light
[Music]
um
and this isn't pre-recorded hello
everybody in chat this is live how are
you
uh yeah this is what is I mean I I can't
talk about stuff and look at chat you
needy pieces of anyway so
like I say man the Elvis movie I enjoyed
it it was a tad too long but I really
did like at the end when they were
showing actual real footage of Elvis uh
before his death and just he had this
really great performance he could barely
walk anymore
you know would it just what is just a
dynamic performer and he came at a time
when the it was like Puritan back then
you know you know he was getting in
trouble for wiggling like dancing he was
getting into moving his hips was like a
slight on society and the and his
connection to black people back then
made it like they were like oh what's he
trying to do and so if you want to hear
about that kind of stuff and again you
want to see Elvis in a very favorable
light I do recommend the movie
um so make sure you uh check out the
Elvis movie I give all this movie maybe
like three woo-woos
that's like three and a half
so check that out man the Elvis movie
all right and the last thing I want to
talk about today is where is it
um this Chris Pratt show I watched on
Amazon Prime called the terminal list
based off this bestseller called the
terminal list
um
you know the movie's about a former Navy
SEAL officer investigates why his entire
platoon was ambushed during a high
stakes covert mission
starring Chris Pratt all right first let
me preface this by saying this I was
watching Real Time with Bill Maher I
really love that show
I liked some of the things he talks
about I like the guests he has on I like
the debate that they have whether you
agree with him or not I like that
there's conversations like that
happening on television
but there was one episode he had where
he was talking about
guns and he was saying
how how hypocritical it is for Hollywood
and Hollywood types to be so anti-gun
but every movie that comes out is
this just gun gun play in every movie
and he was actually showing some of the
movies like John Wick and these kinds of
things and it really made me think like
it really made me think like huh like
like I'm not saying get rid of guns in
movies but maybe it's time to think
about
like maybe PG-13 isn't enough you know
like what do we want to show kids and
it's just that's what it really made me
think about and and he was like you know
it's like how every movie is a Revenge
film and all this kind of stuff and then
cut to
this terminal list comes out and it
basically is a Revenge movie
you know it's a long eight hour Revenge
movie because it's a TV show cut into
eight episodes of miniseries and
you know it just made me think about
it's a lot of gun violence in it it's a
lot of like you know and I'm an adult
I'm a grown ass man and I feel like when
you're a grown ass man you should be
able to watch grown ass man stuff and so
like sometimes I don't like PG-13 I just
don't like it I don't like I don't like
how they make like Wolverine right
they're making a Wolverine movie and
this is PG-13 He's Got Claws that
clearly are gonna cut people up and we
don't see no blood or nothing like that
like what are we doing we leaving it to
the imagination why because you want to
make money and sell stuff to kids I'm
saying not forget them make adult movies
the best Wolverine movie was the rated R
one and the first time those claws came
out and you saw what they the damage
they can really do it was like whoa I
loved it as an adult so maybe it's time
that like like you know John Wick is a
rated R movie so kids aren't supposed to
be in that okay so maybe it's time that
you know let's just make like make
movies for kids kids stuff
13 and 13 14 15 you know they should
have that and then start making like
Avengers and all these type of movies
make them rated R
make them adult just go balls out make
them adult and make them rated R and you
know because maybe we are doing some
damage I don't know I mean I'm not a
scientist so I don't know in in terms of
like does video games cause violence
does seem too much gun violence and
entertainment cause kids to feel a
certain way I don't know
but there are studies about it and if
there is a case if that is true then
let's actually do something about it and
I do agree the Hollywood types the
Hollywood left the media all that stuff
stop being hypocritical about gun
violence when you celebrate it in your
movies that being said because the
reason why I bring this up is I was
thinking about it when I was watching
this but the terminalist basically is a
Revenge film
um and I don't know I enjoyed it because
I like this kind of stuff I just got
finished watch oh man I really should
I I'm gonna I'm gonna say this because
I'll talk about this next week actually
but I I don't know if you guys have ever
seen the movie Old Boy but you have to
watch the movie Old Boy and there's
another Korean movie called I saw the
devil and these are
like oh my God the most graphic
crazy Revenge films you're ever gonna
watch and I can't decide which one
is more gruesome which one is more
sadistic and messed up so my homework
for my Roofing with Griffin audience
right now is I want you to find old boy
and I want you to find I saw the devil
and I want you to watch both of them
because next week I'm going to talk
about revenge films and I'm gonna bring
those two movies up but this show the
terminal list starring Chris Pratt he
executive produced it
I mean it's a TV show I won't spoil it
too much I'm not going to tell you what
happens but basically you know the movie
opens up there on this Mission and the
mission goes wrong
and you know you find out why it went
wrong and who's responsible and some
some stuff unfolds that sends Chris
Pratt's character off on
a Revenge spree and what I like about
the show is that it was basically an
eight hour movie
so they easily could have made the
terminal list movie it would be like an
hour 45 minutes
I'm sure it would they would tie it up
they would show everything and then the
movie would end and you'd be like okay
that was good or bad I can't tell but
what I enjoyed about this and what I
enjoy about making TV shows with big
stars like this is they can really tell
the story and that's the thing I like
about it whether you like the story or
not whether you think this was good or
not I enjoyed the application of the
process of which they did this I enjoyed
all of the uh you know because then they
they did they left no stone unturned you
knew everything you needed to know you
got to know every single character you
got to know you got you were deep into
the plot you you you it was easy to
follow it was and then they just tied it
up they cleaned it up they finished it
and then at the end you were satisfied I
was satisfied that this story is done
and so because of that I enjoyed it
because of that I really really enjoyed
it
um
you know and I like Chris Pratt is the
fact that he was just this kind of
chubby guy from
um what's the uh what's the move the
show with Aziz
come on chat help me out why am I
forgetting it uh with Amy Poehler
it was um just like the office you know
what I mean I don't know why I'm
forgetting the name of it it's just
because I'm old but I like and he's a
funny guy he always was this like fun
funny guy and then he like buffed up for
Jurassic Park or whatever movie it was
and he became like this really like
action star so I I love the parks and
rec thank you everybody Parks and Rec it
was parks and I know everybody listening
right now I was like what's wrong with
this guy how can you forget Parks and
Rec I don't know how I forgot that but
yeah Parks and Recreation great he was
great on that he was so funny and you
know you see him as that character you
don't think someone like that could
become what he became but he did it it's
just a matter of like working out he's a
good looking guy and he just you know
his body looks great when it's in shape
and boom so he became an action star and
he's been in a lot of great action
movies I have not seen a new Jurassic
Park yet but I'm not hearing anything
good about it but I'll probably we watch
it when I'm on in the road I'm going to
Austin so check me out in Austin All You
Texas people I will be at the creek in
the cave 15 16th and 17th in Austin so
make sure you come check me out there
so
um yeah
uh
we're
um weird stuff so like I say I don't
know if anybody saw the terminal list I
don't know if anybody uh in chat right
now watched it but if you have Amazon
Prime I think it's a good watch it's a
fun you know I think it's a fun watch
you know I don't think you're gonna be
disappointed you know you might just be
like oh this is like the same kind of
thing like I say I mean there's a lot of
like you know you know there's nothing
special about the plot per se you know
it's you know like a lot of movies are
the same you know it's like you know
something happens to someone's family
and they have to get revenge you know I
mean that that's basically you know what
it boils down to
and I I always like
I always like military movies
I like there's something about military
movies where I like when they really
display the Brotherhood and commitment
that soldiers have and I think that they
really serviced that in this movie and I
think that sometimes it's even above
your own family there there's a there's
a specialness there's a bond that
military people have with each other
that goes beyond you know when you have
to be out on the battlefield and you
have to look right and look left and you
have to depend on your life by this
person to your right or left and you
also have to look at that person to the
right or left and and you have to make
their life you have to be responsible
for their life to make sure they get
home to their family and this family
unit that is created I really like when
movies display that when they show that
um and this I think this movie does a
good job of that
um anyways guys
um I don't know I think that's uh a good
place to uh to wrap up this episode of
River Griffin
um I think like I say next week I want
to
um next week I wanna I want you to you
have some homework you know if you enjoy
the show I want you guys to watch
old boy find old boy it's out there
someplace it's a Korean film and by the
way watch all these movies in Korean
don't watch the dub diversion okay this
is worth reading it's worth reading
because the performances there's
something about that Korean there's
something about like it just makes it
even more you just really get into it so
watch oh boy and watch I saw the devil
the and then I won't then we're gonna
decide which one is
like more
gruesome just more sadistic Revenge I
because I'm gonna spoil them next week
and I'm telling you from now so make
sure you watch them
um
yeah so spoiler alert from now for next
week but
both I watched both those movies I I had
to watch I just watched I saw the devil
for the first time and man I'm telling
you that movie is
ew y'all that's an ill ass movie so
thank you again for being here
um you know we're just here doing
riffing with Griffin weekly I'm putting
out more content on my tick tock on my
Instagram make sure you watch um you
know thanks for being here with me
Griffin make sure you subscribe make
sure you subscribe share all that good
stuff hit the notifications so you know
when the show's coming online I'm gonna
be on Twitch I'll be on Twitter probably
10 minutes so come check that out and
don't forget about patreon
Eric Griffin on patreon and once again
shout out to my boy British shop for the
PS5 so I'm gonna go on Twitch next and
do an unboxing of my PS5 so make sure
you be a part of that
and thank you for being here I'm gonna
do real world advice from a grown ass
man next week talk about old boy and uh
I saw the devil and whatever else is
going on in the world you know how I am
man thank you for being here and I'll
see you next week
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]